because you recently talked about
Muslims creating the first hospitals in
human history amongst other things
mashallah the first three hospitals in
human history to have psychiatric
sections or Wards within those hospitals
which is truly
an amazing things finally think about it
other civilizations have definitely had
their caring Health Care Systems
hospitals and Care Centers but what you
don't find what's very much missing in
those is a psychiatric mental health
treatments which meant that the Muslims
really understood that you had to be
able to treat mind body and soul
together you couldn't actually separate
them out so their healing institutions
literally in Arabic we say
or in Persian farisi and any of the
uradulla speaking languages you'll know
that the word be mod is illness Stan is
location so the term was be modestense
they had these mental health sections
within their hospitals and that is
unique there's something there that
essentially inspires the Muslims to say
there's no discrimination between
physical health and mental health